pire on voit pas fait d c'est un décès
sérieux et pentue qui a même pas fait
décès les gaulois parce que les gars un
peu problème de légalité par rapport à
ce qu'il a fait qui s'apparentent à des
essais cliniques sauvages qui sont
pénalement réprimés et la nacelle est en
train de s'en occuper justement on voit
que les autorités ont été totalement
lexington laxiste dans cette histoire
pourquoi il a passé lui c'est très
simple parce que quand vous faites un
essai vous avez la preuve que ça marche
ou ça ne marche pas quand est ce qu a
fait un raul ça a été refusé de faire la
méthode qui allait apporter une preuve
de ces propos parce qu'évidemment il
sait très bien que ça fait un siècle
vous savez quand on nous sort la
chloroquine en tout cas la quinine c'est
un dérivé ont déjà mis la 118 ont
expliqué que sa soigner la grippe
évidemment ça soigne pas du tout la
grippe chaque période aux ressources ce
traitement l'a donc didier raoult et je
comprends très bien pourquoi si j'ai pas
la science il fait de la politique donc
il n'allait pas faire le truc qui
allaient montrer potentiellement qu'ils
avaient tort pourquoi on n'a pas fait
ailleurs si on essaye de le faire c'est
laisser discovery en europe mais qui
marche très mal parce qu'elle a eu du
mal à recruter et pour les raisons que
j'ai évoquées tout à l'heure robert day
et plusieurs articles de presse qui
explique ça très bien à ce qu'ils sont
prendre les patients vous l'êtes halak
la chloroquine et pas d'autres choses
le gros pour les u10 chorus et que ceci
est un essai européen tient qu'au lieu
de dire on va se mobiliser en france
pour avoir la vérité on aime ou alors
faire un truc en europe avec les
allemands et les italiens et les
spectres et génial au final il n'y a que
le luxembourg qui nous a rejoint
je crois qu'il va emmener dit madame de
plus un autre le truc est complètement
ridicule
un maquereau nous a promis les résultats
pour le 13 mai donc et bailly chevauche
le tigre donc ça devrait pas tarder à
arriver quand même mais par contre on
voit que peut-être un effet du bas
existe je ne sais pas les anglais eux
ont réussi à faire cet essai à un
recovery qui a montré l'inefficacité
d'un double de chloroquine c'est très
drôle que le raf est de loger les
recrues cet argument là qui est calme
très étonnant et les gens disaient banon
regardez c'est pas bien les gens à en
tester le double de la beuze c'est pour
ça que ça marche pas enfin je veux dire
on n'a pas des pompes de ridicule
[Musique]